[Music]
foreign
Mother's Day is just around the corner
which means that it's time for some woke
virtue signaling from Corporate America
every holiday is an occasion for woke
virtue signaling of course every day in
general is an occasion but Mother's Day
presents a unique opportunity and this
year the virtue signaling is taking on a
perhaps slightly unexpected form the
daily wire reports quote major
corporations and businesses are sending
out emails offering a chance to opt out
of Mother's Day related Communications
and a viral thread posted Sunday Twitter
account Arizona Informer posted more
than a dozen screenshots from businesses
sending Mother's Day opt-out offers
noting the similar language used in the
emails and equating the trend with
anti-family activism Arizona former
caption something very strange is
happening with big corporations out of
nowhere Kroger owned Fry's Food Store
Kay Jewelers Hallmark and now doordash
have all sent opt out of Mother's Day
emails to their customer base this is
not organic the account charge this
reeks of anti-family activism
we understand that Mother's Day might
may be a difficult time for some a
message from doordash said adding an
option to be removed from additional
emails and push notifications relating
to the holiday a message from Kay
Jewelers said we know Mother's Day can
be a challenging time which is why we
want to know if you'd rather rather not
receive Mother's Day related emails
quote with Mother's Day coming up we
understand this could be a difficult
time of year for some
um read a similar email from Nespresso
if you would like to opt out of Mother's
Day emails you can simply click below
Levi's ancestry MAC Cosmetics uh Stitch
fix Bye Bye Baby Etsy and others were
some of the other companies included in
the thread
the list is even longer than this by the
way seemingly all at once you know major
companies across the Spectrum have
jumped on the Mother's Day opt out
trains train and this this is one of the
one of the Hallmarks of wokism is that
you know the the new form of virtue
signaling pops up out of nowhere and in
the blink of an eye everyone is expected
to embrace it even if they have no idea
why they're embracing it you see all
these corporations that are sending out
emails you can opt out of Mother's Day
do they even all know why they're doing
this they just saw everyone else doing
they said oh yeah we got to get one of
those out
in the corporate world especially the
new virtue signal spreads like wildfire
at each company and you know they all
quickly adopt it for fear that being the
last to adopt it might hurt their ESG
score
but don't get too excited this uh
opt-out trend is I think rather Limited
it is it is it is um not an option that
will be offered for other occasions we
can be fairly certain that doordash
isn't going to be offering the chance to
opt out of pride month promotions or you
know black history month spam it's very
unlikely that Levi's or Etsy will send
an email that says we know pride month
can be an extremely annoying time for
you which is why we want to know if
you'd rather not receive pride month
related emails
now this is something that will only be
applied to Mother's Day it probably
won't even extend to Father's day as
well simply because Father's Day is
already mostly ignored you know we've
kind of opted out of that as a society
in general Mother's Day is the holiday
that traditionally gets all the Press
with a great emphasis on making sure
that you shower your mother with gifts
and attention and appreciation
Father's Day on the other hand is a time
to throw a gift bag with a new pair of
socks at your dad and say hey Happy
Father's Day or whatever and then move
on with your day which I can say as a
dad is how we prefer it so I'm not
complaining
the point is that the opt-out trend will
be limited in scope I think
so why are the corporations doing this
and why all of a sudden all at once
the working Theory among conservatives
is that as we mentioned it's rooted in
this kind of woke anti-family ideology
the assumption is that it has something
to do with the left's doctrines on
gender and sexuality Mother's Day
presents a problem for these doctrines
because motherhood presents a problem
and that's why companies are slowly or
not so slowly backing away from it but I
actually don't think
that that's the motivating factor here
mostly because the left doesn't believe
that motherhood presents any problem for
them on this front it does but they
don't think that
the gender ideologue doesn't want to
abolish Mother's Day but rather
appropriate it
which ultimately will have the same
effect as abolishing of course we simply
arrive at that destination from a
different direction but
so I don't think that's the reason
that doesn't mean that the mother's day
opt-out trend isn't woke it certainly is
just for different reasons are you like
me and you still struggle with those
under eye bags and dark circles from
getting up early just to sit down at a
computer the whole day and waste your
life away or unlike me are you getting
ready for a much needed vacation
preparing for some long days in the Sun
and worried about dark sun spots luckily
for you for the first time ever
geniusell is including both the ultra
retinal and Dark Spot Corrector in their
most popular package at genucel.com
Walsh YT genius sells Ultra retinol
contains a powerful retinal alternative
that is safe for your skin their Dark
Spot Corrector will help reduce sunspots
plus you'll still get genu sales
world-class under eye bags therapy to
help alleviate puffiness gender cell
promises immediate effects you'll see
results in 12 hours guaranteed or your
money back you know my Show's production
assistant Zach is basically just a
ginger version of me big beard giant
glasses where's flannel get the picture
one of the nice things about wearing a
giant beard and glasses is that no one
gets to see how disgusting your skin is
well a few months back Zach broke his
glasses when he came to work you got to
finally see how God awful his complexion
is he walked into the room and uh I
vomited all over the floor and I made
him clean it that's how this is a
hostile work environment so like a good
Sweet Daddy I forced Zach to try
genucel's products and it worked like a
charm now well I can't actually see what
his skin looks like because he wears
glasses again he swears his skin tone no
longer matches his reddish orange hair
why would his his glasses prevent me
from seeing his skin anyway that's what
we're going with if you don't want to
look like a lifeless ghoul either visit
genesell.com Walsh YT to save over 100
70 off of their most popular package
every order of subscription includes a
luxury gift box with two free Springtime
Essentials just in time for warmer
weather and free shipping so go to
jennycell.com walshyt geniusell.com
Welsh YT in this case we're told we're
told the reason actually NPR has an
article on the subject about all these
opt-out emails and it explains this
quote many people struggle with Mother's
Day and Father's Day for different
reasons perhaps they've lost parents or
children confronted fertility issues or
they have complicated relationships with
family members as author and grief
Advocate Megan Devine points out there
are so many ways to lose a mother or to
lose mothering
the website Upworthy concurs quote
Mother's Day is an occasion of
Celebration and love for some while for
others it is a painful reminder that
reminds them of grief and fertility
issues or traumatic paths some major
brands have started to realize this
doordash Pandora Mac K Jewelers and
several other companies have sent an
email blasts to their customers
providing them with the option to stop
any sort of Mother's Day branded emails
or promotions
uh quote what can be a wonderful time
for some can be a difficult time for
others Julia brand Pandora wrote in an
April 2023 email to customers we
completely understand if you'd prefer to
opt out Simply let us know and give us
your email and so on this gesture brings
relief to many for whom This Day brings
grief
quote as an infertile person who did
years of medical treatment to get
pregnant I can tell you this opt-out
stuff is not new and it's something
appreciated by infertility and lost
communities and I imagine by people who
have lost parents or have bad
relationships with them according to one
Twitter user so this is the point
Mother's Day is triggering for all the
people who have experienced difficulties
related to their mothers or motherhood
or fertility or childbirth and somehow A
A Mother's Day advertisement is
traumatic according to this logic and
yet having to actively opt out of
Mother's Day ads for dozens of different
brands
is not traumatic that's totally
incoherent of course but the lack of
coherence is another Hallmark of
wokeness you know if my own if my own
mother died God forbid
I would think it'd be much more
emotionally taxing to go into my inbox
and find all of the spam emails and open
them and actively reply to them asking
them not to send me any any Mother's Day
material because my mother is dead
you know I think that'd be much more
difficult than simply just ignoring the
spam uh and uh which goes to the spam
folder anyway most of it
yet one way or another Mother's Day uh
will come and people will celebrate
and yes if you've lost your mother or if
you struggle with fertility or if you
have a bad relationship with your mother
or whatever else
that celebration May conjure up some
difficult emotions for you
but it's not just Mother's Day that will
have that effect when you're struggling
with a serious challenge in your life or
you're grieving over a loss or
experiencing some other kind of deep
emotional pain you'll find a universe
suddenly chock full of signs pointing
back to those wounds and this is true
when it comes to you know very serious
traumas like the loss of a loved one in
your grief you will find reminders of
your loss everywhere you go it's also
true of much less severe but still
significant pains like financial
difficulties
if you've ever if you've ever had
serious money problems you know that
when you have money problems the world
will constantly remind you of your money
problems especially around the holidays
any holiday
and even if there is nothing actively
reminding you of whatever it is you're
struggling with you still are stuck with
your own mind which is keenly aware of
these struggles and constantly turning
them over and dwelling on them no matter
what else is going on in the outside
world
Ness wants to make us Fragile by
encouraging us to Shield ourselves from
these difficult emotional experiences in
fact it tells us that we have the right
to be shielded from them that the world
should reorient itself so that we are
not forced to think about things that
make us uncomfortable
the result is that we never learn to
live with the hardships we only learn
how to live around them avoiding them
hiding from them
that's how we become a country full of
people who cannot cope with any
discomfort whether big or small
always looking for the opt-out option
and unfortunately our society is run by
institutions that are eager to provide
it
which may make us more comfortable in
the moment but they won't help us become
stronger better functioning people in
the long run and that is why these
companies and their Mother's Day opt-out
emails are today canceled now I'll do it
for this portion shows move over to the
members block you can become a member
today by using Code Walsh at checkout
for two months free on all annual plans
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]